the one thing i can say about my journey
that i didn't plan
for any of this and in fact that was
quite resistant
at the beginning
[Music]
i wrote belisa thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you for having me it's a it's
wonderful to have you
and it's going to be wonderful to talk
about your different entrepreneurial
endeavors
a lot of them are social a lot of them
are community i think that if we
if i look at the different things that
you've done along your career perhaps
besides
the legal stuff we're we're looking at a
pretty comprehensive
list of activities that are very much
involving the community and particularly
that of the ecosystem in israel so
wrote tell me a little bit about your
journey leading all the way up to
being to managing at deloitte's catalyst
in israel for startups
well i you know i guess
the the the one thing i can say about my
journey that
i didn't plan for any of this and in
fact
that was quite resistant at the
beginning
um it it started i'd say wise
started about 10 years ago i think it
was
uh 2011. i was just uh
i was just out of the army uh after
three years at uh
8200 um
and the
uh there was there was this thing
facebook was just starting to
share to to let you tag people
in in things and um i
i remember that uh i was very
bent on sharing things with people like
ted talks and
and stuff like that so and and the thing
won't let me
uh wouldn't let me uh tag more than six
people so i created the group
and hoped that it would have about 30 40
people that i know and would
uh um you know uh would would not block
me or unfriend me
and it it kind of took a life on its of
its own
i'd say uh uh it quickly grew to like a
700 people group uh uh that was uh
pretty active at the time
and um you know i'm not going to walk
you through the entire uh
uh group history because it doesn't
really matter but uh
um it was on that venue that that uh
a bunch of us have decided to uh um
create uh an event for for that
community the
i think the the idea was uh um was
originally by uh
uh uh the show's uh friend guy katsovich
uh uh he you know he came to us it came
to me and to
a few other people and said hey why
don't we uh have a community event
i thought it was a good idea you know we
we did it it was
quite successful and then i remember one
time uh
a guy paid me a visit
and said hey i've got this offer to to
do this
at a at the bar um say every once in two
weeks
and my immediate reaction was that's
never gonna work
you know i'm thankful that he has beg to
differ
but the the you know the thing was that
i wasn't uh um
i wasn't really sure that it would
work and knew that we should do it and
uh
ten years later i can tell you that i am
very happy that i was wrong and i think
uh and i think one of the things
that uh uh since then and actually even
before that i've
characterized my approach is that uh
i try to listen and
let uh and let myself be wrong
um it's it's a hard thing to do and i
know a lot of people
talk about failures and being wrong here
it's
it wasn't a failure we were i think
generally speaking was a
it was a success but uh um i was wrong
i thought that it there's no way
it'll work and it kind of did and
was that not kind of i mean wise over
over the over the years has had
hundreds of events impacting thousands
of people i mean it's
it's been a huge success to say the
least
uh yeah i i you know i uh
uh i i i completely agree and it has his
it has
uh uh transformed into something that is
a
uh critical part of my identity and i'd
say that
um but i always
whenever i'm asked about it i always
start with
the fact that i was at the beginning i
never thought it would work and i mean
to this day i'm really not sure why it
still does
but i i i think i am we are fortunate
uh um that that it still does and that
uh people in israel are
very excited about the things we do and
about the events
and the content we bring but
you know i i guess i guess the first few
years of wise kind of gave me the
confidence
that i needed in order to do more things
or more endeavors and
i think one of the things that changed
about me the most is
that i kind of realized that
if it won't work it'll be fine i mean
you know uh the the term we like to use
in israel is is fail fast fail
often and i think part of my uh um
one of my strategies was or one of my
strategies till this very day
is okay i mean fine
if it won't work it won't work we'll
just you know pick up uh
um you know pick up the uh the debris
and uh move forward and i think it it
has been
uh um it has been a uh um
kind of like a cornerstone of of the way
that i you know approach uh uh
new things and it's not easy emotionally
it's not easy for me i'm uh i
i think i'm a relatively conservative
person at
nature and and i keep trying to
push myself into new things because
um you know because it has proved out to
be
a a generally
good strategy i'd say
right so so you once we move past wise
you've implemented the same
mindset into all the different endeavors
that you've done so talk to me a little
bit about them
and and how did you bring that mindset
to develop these
well again i think so we we did
learn a lot at wise all of us
all the people who were involved and all
the people who are still involved we
learned
so much so much about
anything from operations and making sure
that
things run on time and
you know all the way up to leadership we
we incorporated a uh
a non-profit i'd say in 2012 or
something
uh as a as a um
an association and you know we
when you when you form an association
you have to have a board of directors
but really when you are a five to ten
people operation
that really doesn't matter and
especially when you you were
22 or 23 i i didn't realize what it
meant to be a board member and it didn't
really mean anything at the time
but i think as as we grew and as
uh uh i've spent more time doing
uh you know doing uh
the work in the first few years and then
kind of transitioning to how
to to letting you know to managing
uh individuals and uh uh
what what is now teams um you know i
think
i i've learned a lot uh in in terms of
what does it mean
to to manage what does it mean to lead
uh and um in in in
in a way i think that we kind of grew
at least the the people who are now on
the board we kind of grew into the role
um and i think that today if i um
if i uh think about it then then
um the
[Music]
the thing that you know that was most
impactful is to know how to take a step
back and also
bring other people in trust them
delegate effectively work with them
in some cases even mentor them and
really letting other people share
that uh thing that that we've created
about
10 years ago right so it's not just the
community that's
that's you know the customer base or the
people that are using the product or
or or leveraging the association and the
non-profits work but it's also
internally the people that are they're
running it
and of course i'm assuming that when
you're we're discussing non-profits and
these sorts of associations and
you need the people there to first of
all be very in
right you need to really loop them in
you need to really make it a community
and primarily because this is non-profit
work and the motivations for
for volunteering your time at a
non-profit work are very very different
than
being a board member of a for-profit
startup perhaps right 100
i think that in a non-profit um
you know the the internal motivations
are
almost all you have i mean in in a
for-profit organization or in a startup
it's always a mix between the the money
and like the compensation and the
the internal uh uh motivation which is
very important if you want to have an
a-team then you definitely need that
it's just that in a non-profit that's
pretty much all you got
uh and um when you're when you're
dealing with volunteers especially and i
i think that that
the the key idea is
to help people find meaning in their
work
and that's really not easy it's not easy
for
for you know
it's not easy because people have
different
agendas and they have different
personality structures and
people need different people need
different
levels of guidance and different levels
of
of support some people are more
independent and they just want to go for
it
and some people need the guidance and i
think that
that that commitment is is um
something that that can manifest itself
in in
in different ways and it never stops
let me give you an example uh uh from
from this day and age um
corona hits and you know
we had to transition from the the
bars environment and the offline
environment
to the online environment and you know
as technical as it sounds it was also a
profound change
one of the reasons it's such a profound
change is not because
well it is because people consume the
content
online and not in the bar but it really
impacted our volunteers
uh because the dna of our organization
was the physical interaction with one
another
in bars it was for for our
our uh volunteers and for our staff
uh as much as it was for our audience
now it took us it took us a while
to understand how uh um
you know how dramatic the change is
and we are still undergoing a process
where we are trying to
to redefine what it means to volunteer
at wise now
the to to be very honest
uh and i think it it it is
you know it is crucial to say that
uh while you know while we as
as the the organization's leadership
kind of
had to step back and think about what we
can do differently and how
we can re redefine the meaning of being
a volunteer at wise
it is it was and it will be a team
effort
and we need all of our volunteers and
all of our staff
to be committed to this and if they're
not committed then maybe we're doing
something wrong
um and just to finish the thought
um you know the
the the the key issue in in
in all of this is that uh
you know you make mistakes you you test
something in the field you make more
mistakes
you try to implement it and you
basically try to be
honest and transparent enough about it
in order to
uh uh in order to
[Music]
be successful in order to transition
well from one environment to another
a hundred percent no and the impact that
wise has had is is phenomenal
but you've also taken part in quite in a
few other activities
as a board member particularly both of
the israel internet association but
but even more exciting for me the alumni
association for 8200.
so talking about your activity there and
what lessons have you brought
from wise to this association
and in your learnings well so i i didn't
start off as a board member
i started as the uh uh as a uh
newsletter editor uh and i
uh uh you know i was i i volunteered
there and i spent a lot of time doing
that about i'd say about
two or three years um and uh
i i and i think for this the the
it was a very busy time for me
personally with school and work
and uh a few other commitments and whys
and uh same thing i just decided to go
for it and see if it'll work
and uh i i just
really enjoyed uh the journey
and uh then at some point where i
entered the the board of directors
um i'd say that uh uh i i did
bring a lot of the things i didn't do
well
at wise the all the things that didn't
really work well for me or didn't really
work well
in general in all of my missteps i just
tried to learn learn back from them and
the the the alumni association is a much
different organization and and i love it
dearly i'm still
very much involved and i keep on wanting
to be more and more involved i love the
organization i think it's
a phenomenal platform for uh
impact both on our members and our
alumni but also
on on the the israeli society and
um i i think that that you know one of
the things that
i kind of brought with me is
trying to learn how to be a good
board member which is
which is a a very tricky thing to do
because as a board member oftentimes you
have a kind of like an internal struggle
between
right uh being you know
you want to be there you want to get
things done you want to be active but
you have to remember
it's not your job your job
is as a board member of course is
to weigh in is to be
strategic to be thoughtful to help
to offer help if you can and also be a
part of the conversation
it is i i think one of the one of the
things
that uh um you know one of the things
that i carry on to this very day is
um that a and this is something that a
friend
told me i think originally it came from
uh stef bertheimer but
i don't know personally so i can't test
but a board member does
three things they
uh appoint a ceo they fire a ceo
and they ask how can i help and i
think the problem starts when board
members
in general not saying not necessarily
uh you know in any organization but the
problem is is where board members
act as um executives
that's where usually where the problem
starts now we didn't have a ceo for a
while for
several years but now we we do we have
for about the last year and a half
and i think that for me personally uh uh
it it kind of was an opportunity to test
the
the my my ability to be
an effective board member and right and
not to be
in and to be there for the ceo or to
support
uh and not to
you know want to take charge which is
never uh a good thing
well that's it that that's fascinating
so what were some of your
responsibilities or what was your
experience
being a more member if you're looking
across the board uh
ironic for these three organizations
what what key insight do you have to
potentially other board members that
of how they can really be helpful and
and non-classroom because this is a
topic that has come one
time and time again on this show of what
it means to be a supportive and helpful
board member versus one that may be
clashing or disruptive to the process
so so i'd love to hear you know one or
two key insights
from your experience that's an excellent
question
um there's a couple of things
one is the the
the role the role of the board
in my mind is to provide
strategic um and they say this
strategic guidance to the executives
it is and i think that
um in in you know
a board can be too involved and it could
also be too detached and both things
aren't great it really
takes it takes a very very
uh uh you know it takes being
very minded and very thoughtful
in order to create the balance
between you know being too involved and
too detached right um
i i think that there's a conception
there's a
and just to add on that thought there's
a conception that you know a board needs
to do
their work full time and maybe in a in a
you know fortune 500 company they're
have they they have to be
you know doing their job con like
uh as a full-time gig maybe i don't know
i've never been on a
fortune 500 board but uh uh
but i think that from my experience the
the key issue is to work with your
executives to strike the right balance
there's no one
answer really depends on what your
executives need
so that's one thing striking the right
balance between
uh being too much involved and not being
involved at all
uh the second thing is
um as a board member not necessarily as
a board but as a board member
uh and this is gonna sound very cliche
but i i still think it's
it's incredibly important it's crafting
a good and helpful relationship with the
ceo
and with his leadership team and the key
to crafting a good relationship
is to show that you're you know you're
there you're active you you're
interested you're willing to put in the
time
but you're not there to step on their
toes
at a certain time you have to be able to
take a step back
and say i'm i've said my piece
i'm not going to get too involved
and and you know
i've done this i i i was wrong at this
many times i have over kind of stepped
my boundaries
as a board member i have been too
involved and sometimes i've been too
detached
and to be very honest i
i'm still trying to figure out what's
the correct
word for sorry what's the correct
balance for each right board that i'm in
and the last thing the last insight if
you want to call it
uh is um different boards
have different dynamics and
as to be an effective board member you
have to be able to read those dynamics
right and take and kind of
choose what role you want to play now
a a good friend once told me that the
person needs to be
needs to know when they are in charge
and when
they are you know followers and
or the way he said it was is typical to
israel a person needs to know when he's
a commander or a soldier
yes and and i think it's it's incredibly
important especially for
for and it's actually easier for people
who sit on on on several boards but
the the idea is is that you
you know different boards have different
dynamics and they tend to have
different levels of conversation
and i think that you want to decide
how active and in what ways
you can be and what is your role
on on that board and i'll give one
example uh
in my role in the in
in the group dynamic in the uh internet
association is
profoundly different than what it is
or why the alumni association in the
sense that
there are things for example in the in
the uh
um in the organization's uh
activities that i i don't have a lot of
input
for example there's a lot of uh
technical issues that
that have to do with how do we make sure
that that the
nation's servers are uh uh are kept
afloat
honestly nothing i have nothing to say
about this
so yeah right no no that makes a lot of
sense
i really want to thank you for for
shining light for me and for everybody
else that's listening about the
responsibilities of a board member
and and more importantly the the
positive ways to make
a positive impact on a board and i think
that it's a it
i'm excited to to take part in these
activities myself one day and then i'm
definitely
going to take a lot of these lessons to
heart so thank you for being generous
with your time and sharing that with me
and before we go around i'd love to ask
you the most important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
wow i'd say optimistic
conservative and thoughtful
i love that and i think that it's a
going by
but what we discussed today about your
different responsibilities that's
exactly what you're what you're exerting
so so thank you for the inspiration for
that
and stay safe and stay healthy and best
of luck with all these amazing
amazing communities thank you for having
me
and as everybody says it's all about the
people
so thanks everybody thank you for having
me and thanks everybody for
being a part of the ride